91 scientists made a discovery and they
discovered every human heart about 40 40
000 or so specialized cells configured
in a way that creates a neural network
in the heart it's their brain-like cells
but they're not in the brain they're in
the heart and these 40 000 specialized
cells are called sensory neurites these
cells think independently of the cranial
brain they feel and they remember
independently of of the cranial brain
and what that means is every experience
that we have even this one right now I'm
registering this experience in two
places I'm registering it in my mind and
as well as in my heart but if we were
having a trauma it would still be
registered in both places and if I tried
to heal that trauma only through
thinking about it it might feel
incomplete the healing may feel
incomplete and the reason is because
I've only addressed what happened in
here I haven't addressed what happened
in here